bootleg cat podcast man we got the homie
graph in the building graph what's good
brother hey hey what up though oh yeah
I'm out here I'm out here what's good
with it what's going on in L.A man you
told me he was out here ghost writing
yeah man I do a lot of uh creative
writing
record placements and just you know
supporting other artists and [__] like
that as well as my own stuff coming up
you got the new album 38 Special yes sir
shout out to my 38 Special album is out
right now call all the words it's
[__] fire real hip-hop culture [__]
uh what's coming up what's on the way uh
quiet as cat me and 38 got another album
about to come out you know what I'm
saying so guys we're running it back
spinning the block cooked up a two-piece
for y'all man so on the second one it's
just as dope as the first the first one
is fire though I got gigs on there uh 38
of course
Rome streets is on there Bun B stole god
um
I put out another album please stop a
lot of dope shot the stove somebody else
on there oh Davies is on there well so I
don't remember it's a crazy lineup yeah
I shot it I try to [__] with this video
zombies on every album I have a drop
down I don't know if you know that
that's like a like a graph fun fact
I think only good energy is not only but
every mixture everything everything
everything I put out you kind of know at
this point like my bro it's my big bro
I'm calling my hey man it's not even a
thing which is but it's a thing you know
what I'm saying like it's just that's my
man so it's my it's like my big bro
shout out to Bun B well look let's get
two of my guys one of the nicests who
came up here to do what he does so
that's indeed facts indeed all right
what's up
hey hey what's up my name gravo gang
[__] New York City but I put it though
um hey what's up dog
hey
[Music]
when I'm snatching your plate and you
catch a grenade boom like back in the
days when my OG would grab the remote
back in the day room hey stay tuned your
favorite rappers on crackery a Strong's
trying to top what I'm spitting dams and
[__] both of those are not what I'm
giving rocks I was pitching on the Block
for a living now by this curate design
clothes and get [__] shot for a living
look at my Ig it looked like I shot for
a living I break nose bones Fistful of
snot for a living I'm straight crazy
they lazy things they pay me I want a
hundred I'm grinding [__] I take 80. it
shake shaky it works fresh cause I bake
daily I started stepping them Sadie
skirt industry homies that know me I
think they fake lately I cut the grass
the lawnmower left snake gravy jealous
friends the hate hate me I impregnate
heroin eggs and make babies my style is
kind of al-Qaeda I am now riding through
Wildfire I will not put the iron down I
am I iron pounds lying right inside of
my tie up I design Crown I'm inspired by
desire y'all to wire down with wires
around your liar I am the higher power
Aya I devour you will ask Amaya I fried
Chihuahuas but the fire firefighters
Gotta Fight for hours I fry your power
the right thing driving in the grease
cooking like a fried Wing when the pipe
swings doing the right thing disrespect
I shoot him in a migraine but
I got my web game up Instagram hoes
trying to [__] my bed frame up Google my
name and the check came up my mind free
but my neck chained up blinging
but I represent the Soul Purpose I'm a
boss but I represent the co-workers
ain't no purpose in working for
leftovers that are left over coal
Burgers you get no service for your stay
at last fries my chain for the frozen
rain and you ain't seen drops of hair
last size who the hell raised hell that
high roasting but the water in my Kettle
Frozen it's cold outside still holding
and God said I'm still chosen but when I
look out the window it's still snowing
the school's all closed but prison is
still open there ain't no safety and the
one on my pistol is still broken can't
say I didn't do it the pistol is still
smoking the liquor store didn't close oh
to be done the [__] run that [__] back I
got more bars running back [__] I'm
taking it from right there hold on hey
hey what's up PC what up though yeah
gang [__] oh hold on
hey
[Music]
so
stupid I'm about mine now I said the
world is yours is now mine what a foul
line you wanna had a ground fine you get
outlined time is money it's about time
[__] it's about time it's about Sean
finna go ham it's about swine prick tell
your mama that I'm world famous and I'm
a porn star I can make your girl famous
I turn a bum [__] to the world's
greatest take off that cheap fur coat
made of squirrel anus and let me put you
in this long ass [__] I pop big bottles
and I pour tall ass drinks um rock
chains for the long-ass mix no I'll
never sleep I just take long ass blinks
baby uh I'm working my jacket made of a
snake skin serpent you know I eat
rappers alive curtains you can smell
dead rapper when I'm burping excuse me
what's up
my name grab hoe you already know man
appreciate you brother that was crazy
indeed indeed hello hello
gang [__] hey I know you just watched
the new freestyle guess what we're
dropping them every week sometimes more
than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off your checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week